dreaming
and caring
when I look back you know it would think
I wanted to make that movie because I
was in my late 30s and I was looking
back at the different cells that I had
been and points in my life and and I
have this I'm sure over a man to sized
vision of myself as a 12 or 13 year old
that's just being so vibrant and kind of
clear I'd you know clarity of vision
like really knowing what I wanted to say
and being just filled with creativity
and then at the end of my adolescence
the other end you know of of you know
getting into my adulthood I I was sort
of the opposite i just i lost all of my
agency and my secret you know Shane was
that I could only be an artist as an
actor because I need it I didn't have
any words of my own you know basically I
needed to speak other people's words and
it was the only way in for me to keep
connected to a creative play